[Music]  my name is maria bartoromo i've been  with fox for eight years the defining  moment for me at fox was hosting a  presidential primary debate what is your  plan  the producer made sure that we knew  every subject what are our buckets what  do we want to cover in this debate and  we all had our own ideas we talked two  hours about those ideas and then he said  okay come back in one week and we'll do  it again and we did it again and again  and again i mean it was amazing  and i was scared  you wanted to do this again okay i'll  come up with new ideas i was at another  network for 20 years i did a  presidential debate at that network i've  never seen the kind of prep that i saw  at fox we came out  confident because preparation leads to  excellence  [Music]  you